hello everybody and welcome to my
YouTube channel
this is a quick Monday update
um it's kind of like a follow-up from
the Sunday update that I posted last
night on Twitter
um basically you can already start to
see Bitcoin triggering the move because
if you notice here you watch a bit
closely you can see one two three tops
button and drop okay now most of you
will be wondering what's next what is
going to drop to okay so what I see in
the chart I already mentioned this in
the Sunday update is this area over here
okay if I Mark in the chart will be in
the 20
730 dollars okay this is you can see the
Bitcoin range for about
that's the 19th of March
until the 10th of April last three weeks
three weeks of consolidation in this
Zone
so obviously this area should should be
tested as a as a potential support okay
I talked about the dollar Index last
week and how it was potentially forming
a w pattern and also the inverse
correlation with Bitcoin because Bitcoin
trades against the dollar essentially
okay so I'm gonna take you to the dollar
index in a second
this is the chart the daily time frame
and you can see very clear this
potential level view pattern also
something that I really like about this
is how it swept the lows you can see
with this week over here
okay swap the previous lows and now it's
marching on if you go into the one hour
time frame you can see the since Friday
it's bouncing pretty hard okay and
that's also a reason why Bitcoin is
dropping
if you go to the four hour time frame we
can see that the volar index is
approaching some very important zones in
the chart okay and I mean these two
zones over here
what we saw the previous sell-offs
happening okay and these are the two
previous highs also if you go to the
Daily time frame we can see that the 50
EMA
is around that area so what the logic is
telling me is that it's very likely
that we see
the bowler going towards these zones
and then we could see a rejection and
that's where Bitcoin could do the
exactly the opposite could go up
let's have a look at the liquidation
charting High block if we go to the
seven days time frame we're gonna be
able to see the logic behind this move
for Bitcoin Okay so let's get this shown
I think this was
in the weekend and you could see that
Bitcoin was between two very important
liquidity zones today upside we had 31
300 and to the downside we had 29 100.
so in my opinion what happened here is
that
first the bowler was looking very
bullish because on Friday
it bounced pretty hard so the most
likely essenerio was the bit
convolutional range in the weekend
because you know that the dollar Index
is closed on on weekends and then on
Monday when the dollar can trade we
would see continuation for that bouncing
the dollar Index and then continuation
for Bitcoin to the downside okay so that
was pretty much what I wanted to say in
the Sunday update anime previous to it
that's why
we have here a very interesting zone
right below us 29 100.
well it gets my attention is that you
can see Bitcoin went to 29 200.
just so close to 29 100 and went up this
to me is a liquidity Rune to the upside
to make people open more Longs so the
Liquidations in this area and the stop
losses can increase and then when they
come down
they're gonna hit more stop losses and
more liquidations okay so I think that
Bitcoin will eventually go to 29 100
this week
um but you can see that there is even a
lot more liquidity in 29
000 28 900 28 850 that is still quality
liquidity in this area so we could of
course go below 1029 100.
going back to the Bitcoin chart we can
see how this level that we marked over
here that it was the previous resistance
matches with those Liquidations in high
block okay which is very interesting
how the previous resistance that in
principle should be tested next as a
support has a lot of liquidity
okay this this this really gets my
attention and that's also why I think
that Bitcoin can go to this area now if
you remember the dollar chart that we
were looking at earlier we were
expecting the dollar to go higher to
attack those two important zones in the
chart and then we could see a reaction
in the dollar
now
if the dollar goes higher that means
that Bitcoin is going to go lower and
then if a dollar gets a rejection
Bitcoin can bounce okay so that is the
trick that I'm looking at now I'm gonna
try to see what happens in lower time
frames in this area but I think that 29
100 should be tacked this week
um then from there we will see if we can
go all the way to 28 730 and in this
area we're here we can look for bounces
so that's pretty much everything that I
wanted to to say in this first YouTube
video
um as is the first video please show all
the support that you can share give it a
like
and the most important tell me if you
like the video or not and if you want to
see more
so that's pretty much everything thank
you guys for watching and I see you soon